the Justice Department reportedly is
investigating whether uber stole trade
secrets from its competitors the
allegations come from richard jacobs
ubers former manager of global
intelligence jacobs claims uber has a
secret internal unit gathering
intelligence on rivals hiding evidence
and influencing lawsuits this was
revealed in a letter by jacobs lawyer
prosecutors claimed uber wanted to keep
the letter secret it surfaced in a
lawsuit accusing the ride-hailing giant
of swiping technology from way mo now
that's the self-driving car division of
alphabet the parent company of Google a
federal judge delayed the trial
yesterday accusing ubers lawyers of
withholding the letter as evidence in a
statement uber tells CBS this morning
none of the testimony changes the merits
of the case Jacobs himself said on the
stand that he was not aware of any way
mo trade secrets being stolen CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson is
editor-in-chief of Wired and he joins us
at the best Nick good morning morning
Vlad so why is Wei most suing uber for
at least half at least a billion dollars
not even half a billion dollars so one
of the top engineers who helped design
Google's self-driving cars left
downloaded all of Google's proprietary
technology on lidar the little thing on
the top of the car that sprays lasers
that's like really technologically
complex downloaded all the information
about that and then shortly thereafter
created a new company that was quickly
acquired by uber so Google really thinks
that he took all of their technology and
brought it to Eber and so that's why
they brought the case and how does this
case look to you you've been you've
spending a lot of time looking at it you
talked to her lawyers last night cake so
my general take on the case is that the
actual departure of Anthony Lewandowski
looks really dark and really nefarious
like he really did download the stuff he
really did take it there really were
like it seems like a bit of a
co-inky-dink walks on the Embarcadero on
the other hand we've now been
investigating this for a long time and
there is no smoking gun there is no
direct piece of Google technology in the
uber self-driving cars so it actually
looks really dark behavior but that ever
has a pretty good chance of winning the
case until this bombshell yesterday yeah
but we've also learned a lot about how
Ober operates right yeah so that was the
amazing thing yesterday so this letter
says well ruber we had this secret
division it had CIA employees we had
ways that
sending messages to each other that
would be immediately deleted we had all
of these computers that were off the
uber system which we would use and only
the dummies would use the regular uber
computers so that could explain why all
this information could have been taken
from Google and not discovered in the
trial you said there's no smoking gun
but is it a black eye for goop not
Google for uber I don't know who burr
has enough eyes to have them all be
black at this point I mean the hack last
week was a black eye there's about the
hundredth black eye for uber on the
other hand uber does have a defense here
right they say this guy Jacobs well he
kind of walked back on some of the
letter was written by his lawyer he only
reviewed it for 20 minutes on the
holidays so maybe the letter has some
exaggerations in it not only that a lot
of companies have systems for sending
messages they get deleted there are lots
of reasons why you might want to have
computers off the main network just you
can look at rivals on LinkedIn well
Wayne Moe is weighing in and they're
saying the evidence brought to light is
significant and troubling so how could
the evidence impact the trial well I
think what it's going to do is it's
going to change the perception of uber
and the judge is saying wait a second
how can I trust you if you have this
letter and it has his information about
this detailed spine organization and you
didn't give it to me this letter was
written last spring and we've been
working on this how can anybody trust
anything you say to it which IRB's
responses look the letter doesn't
actually say that much and it's not
about way mo the letter is just about
uber and in fact we had discovery and
the the letter didn't show up because it
doesn't have any of the particular
search terms that we agreed we would
look for well is there during a case you
certainly raise some reasonable doubt
their name yes the law school or
something thank you Nick Thompson always
good to have you at the table
the right to be here